hello and welcome to simply line today
we're going to be giving you a
kubernetes tutorial we'll provide the
overview of how and why you should be
using kubernetes but before we get
started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're gonna
go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're gonna cover what
cupola teas is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get to refer to
quite frequently and then we do a deep
dive into the actual kubernetes
architecture itself and how kubernetes
runs and operates within your network
and then finally we're gonna look at
some kubernetes use cases of how you can
actually apply best learnings that other
companies have used with kubernetes well
finish everything off with a demo where
we actually step through and use some of
the actual codes that you can actually
use to run from your terminal window to
actually activate kubernetes itself so
with that said let's jump in so my
kubernetes well kubernetes is really
being built from allowing you to be able
to have a more reliable infrastructure
the tool itself is designed to manage
the containers you have within your
network it's very modular in
architecture which allows it to be very
easy to be able to maintain and to be
able to scale and meet the demands that
your current customers are offering you
today the actual ability for you to be
able to deploy and update software at
scale is really at the heart and center
of kubernetes is really one of the
reasons why kubernetes was created was
to be able to scale up the deployment of
software into tens of thousands of
networks and servers within a data
center and then finally when you start
working with kubernetes really what
you're doing is
laying the foundation for building cloud
native applications and pod this comes
from the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by Google Google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the data structure than
data infrastructure that they had within
their network they really liked it and
one of the big benefits they Cuban it
that Google provided is that they
converted their code into an open source
program that they released as kubernetes
in 2014 and made an open source this
means that any company can use
kubernetes there's no charge for it all
you have to do is know how to use the
command line strategy get up and running
the benefit of kubernetes being open
source is that most cloud providers now
support kubernetes so whether you're
using Microsoft Azure you're using
Google cloud or AWS you'll find that you
can actually use kubernetes and
kubernetes and
at a core really helped eliminate manual
processes or allowed for deploying and
scaling your container based solutions
much more effortless within a cloud
environment so this jump into the
features of kubernetes and why you'd
want to be using it and we have a number
of features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across the entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10,000 doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before
connexes also will manage the actual
containers themselves I'm including the
security and the storage and the
networking within those containers the
great benefit of working with kubernetes
is that not only is it a cloud centric
solution but it was really
from a core need of a secure solution so
security is at the heart and center of
all the work you're doing which really
helps benefit any teams scaling out
containers your kubernetes environment
will be constantly monitored there so
that when you have nodes that have your
containers the health of those nodes is
being constantly communicated back to
code the kubernetes environment so that
the entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes if
something does go wrong you can actually
set up your kubernetes environment to do
an automatic rollback again this is just
allowing you to have that confidence
that when you're deploying a solution
that everything is going to work within
that environment and then finally
kubernetes will allow you to mount and
add the storage needed to run your apps
so whether you have storage such as a
local SSD storage device physically on
the hardware or if you're connecting to
storage fire the cloud kubernetes will
allow you to access the storage you need
how you're accessing it so let's look a
little bit into the differences between
kubernetes and docker swarm so if we
just step back a little bit kubernetes
and docker often get connected with each
other
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and docker is really famous
for creating the most popular container
management solution which is called
docker
if you're a developer you're probably
already using docker today so one of the
things that kubernetes is really really
good at is that it manages containers at
scale and just massive volume of
containers docker swarm is Dockers
alternative to kubernetes it's a tool
that allows you to also manage large
number
large numbers of containers there are
differences between the two of them and
right now without doubt the most popular
open source solution out there is
kubernetes from google it just has a
massive community behind it and the
community
really have embraced kubernetes and yes
the original product was by developed by
google but google has been great
stewards and they've allowed the
community to drive the future evolution
of the product docker swarm is a team
managed and developed by docker
there is a smaller community but it is
also a very passionate community and the
reason being is that both products are
actually pretty good and you just really
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built 4
cuban at ease simply because the
community is just so much bigger than
the docker swamp community but with that
said dr. swarm is really easy to set up
so if you are used to working within the
doctor environment you'll be able to set
up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
Microsoft Azure or Google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment
kubernetes has extremely high fault
tolerance again it's because kubernetes
is has been ro tested with foundation
for kubernetes is based on managing
sites such as Gmail Google comm YouTube
I mean just incredibly robust
environment compared to docker swamp
which has lower fault tolerance and and
this really kind of leads into the final
area is where kubernetes does guaranteed
strong clusters and management just a
really reliable environment dr. Swamy
however is able to take containers
deploy them into large clusters very
very quickly two interesting differences
is that with kubernetes the load
balancing is still manual and be
interesting to watch how kubernetes
matures that skill set
in contrast load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements and if you're interested
and she having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well so the way that kubernetes runs is
that it uses node strategy you manage
all the individual Hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine in a data center or a
virtual machine and when you are setting
up an environment on a cloud environment
such as Microsoft Azure or Google cloud
or AWS kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually worked with the cluster as
a whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to imagine the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster it's very very flexible
within kubernetes you can have local
storage such as an SSD card or a
traditional local storage or you can
actually connect to the cloud and use
cloud-based storage and the benefit that
cloud-based storage offers you is that
you are increasingly moving your
solution into more of a hardware free
environment cloud-based architecture
where you're not reliant on a physical
piece of hardware within your data
center and why that's important is that
it gives you the opportunity to scale up
your solutions much more effectively so
if you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud whereas local hardware is a
little bit harder to match great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from until the the next
layer down is the actual management of
the application that's within a
container and let's mentioned earlier
docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're already using docker as
it was a natural maturity from using a
virtual machine but kubernetes itself
let you manage the containers that you
have within you
notes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes where
actually manage the health of that pod
serve a container or a pod fales
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pots themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes but you really
want to let kubernetes do this because
it's allowing you to step away from the
manual management of pods your
environment is just gonna be healthier
relying on kubernetes to do the actual
management of all the pods you have out
there so you are able to allow access to
from surfaces outside of your kubernetes
and this is done through a process
called ingress and going back earlier we
talked about how security is a key part
of all the work that goes into
kubernetes and this is a great example
of where you can use an external service
but still have that layer of security
that is vital for your solution because
to be able to provide the ingress
connection kubernetes requires an ssl
connection which automatically allows
for a secure data transfer absolutely
fantastic so here we have an overview of
the actual architecture on the right
hand side we have our nodes and the pods
within our nodes and within those pods
are the containers on the left hand side
we have the master architecture and the
master architecture is the actual brains
behind the work that you're doing it's
actually managing the schedules the
controllers for all of the nodes and
then and the bottom left-hand side we
have commands which are written on a
local workstation and those commands are
pushed up to the master so let's kind of
dig a little bit further into the
architecture of the master so the master
itself is comprised of a number of key
components and again this is the tool
that's going to manage your entire
kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the
etcd control manager scheduler
API server and the key four components
are ET CTE or the cluster store the
control and manager the scheduler and
the API server the cluster store is the
tool where all the details of the work
that you're doing is stored and it's
going to manage the rules you can
imagine all the instructions and this is
where you're gonna post that information
the controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to all the pods and nodes
within your network and then finally you
have an API server which allows you to
be able to control all the operations
the actual operations themselves are all
instructions written as rest
instructions which allows you to take
advantage of the security that has been
built in to rest and so you end up with
a worker slave architecture and slaves
are all the different nodes and pods
within your network and so a part itself
will have multiple one or more multiple
containers and then each container and
then each part will have a docker
container Akoo blades and a kubernetes
proxy and indeed these are tools to
allow you to communicate back up to the
master layer so the docker is the actual
container itself and this is going to
actually run your application and the
instructions here are to pull down the
correct container from the docker images
that you have within your library the
cubelet is going to emerge your
containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written
either yamo or JSON format gamal is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with llamó I so encourage
you to do so it's very easy to pick up
if you know any XML you'll pick up
yellow very quickly and finally the
kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions front that are
pushed to the couplet and to dock it to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there
are a lot and if you're doing any work
today in the cloud and even if you're
just starting up and doing some simple
example working the cloud there's a
really good chance that you are using
kubernetes but some of the companies
that you would probably not surprised
are using kubernetes are Spotify Sapa
eBay and of course some of the the big
companies out there Google with their
entire network of solutions and
Microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a step into a you but now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're gonna
look at the New York Times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their IT department was struggling with
so when New York Times started working
after their data centers there their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMs but
the problem is is that as the New York
Times became more of a digital company
they started building more digital
solutions and at some point they
realized that what they needed to do was
to embrace the cloud and move all their
solutions to a cloud however their first
step of using the cloud and this is I
think typical for a lot of companies is
that they treated 8 the cloud hosted
provider in the same way as they would
with a data center and they at some
point they realized they had to take a
change and this is where the development
team and came in and they said look how
about we stop thinking of our solutions
as a data center even though they're
being run in Amazon I start thinking
them as cloud first solutions and so
what they proposed and what they ended
up doing was using Google cloud platform
with kubernetes as a service and to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using communities they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
surgeons at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time but
uptime for the actual infrastructure
update began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified
to deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the New York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
New York Times website so this finally
kind of looking to some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six times that
we're going to look through and we'll
let you read through this but we have a
cluster which is a set of machines
fiscal vertical in which applications
are managed and run we have a node that
are the worker machines that run
containerize applications and other
workloads there is the pod which is
within a node and is a group of
containers that have deployed together
on the same host we have replication
controllers a replication controller is
you define a paused lifecycle rather
than to create the pods directly we have
a selector which is an expression match
label to filter specific resources
labels are key value pairs that are
attached to objects such as pods and the
key value pair or the label can be
filter organized and perform operations
on resources replication sense define
how many replicas of each pod will be
running and managed when you want to
either replace a pod when it dies
annotation is a label with much larger
data capacity a name is a resource as it
is identified volume is the directory
which data is accessible to a container
namespaces provide additional
qualification to resources name and then
finally service in an abstraction of a
top tier pods which provide a single IP
address and dns name by which the pods
can be accessed so at this time what we
want to do is take you through
kubernetes demo that you runs through
some of these basic controls so I'm
gonna take you through a video of how to
actually install kubernetes and to use
some of the basic instructions so
kubernetes is the most popularly put
used platform format container
management the first step is to our
chain store the necessary to
pregnancy's so let's see if there's any
updates first so the first so to check
that there's any updates we use the
command sudo apt-get update we're gonna
enter in our password and this looks
like it's gonna take a few minutes
because we've got a few updates that
need to be running all right we're done
alright next we're going to write sudo
apt-get install - y apt - transport
- HTTP and this will install all the
dependencies we need to Reggie start
installing the solutions needed for
kubernetes alright and that was quick
now we're going to put in the docket
dependency and the way we do that is
write the command sudo apt install
Daugherty Oh typo correct there quickly
and put in Y so the yes continue and
it's going to take a while because we're
going to download and install docker off
the internet and it's quite a large
installation now would be a good time to
go get a cup of coffee because it'll
take us about a minute to get this all
done once we actually have dr. installed
we'll let you go ahead and we'll start
darker and enable darker using our
pseudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start enabled dagger we're going to
using so they use sudo systemctl start
ducking and sudo systemctl enable danke
so be quite quick so the next step is to
install all the components for Cuban
unities and we're going to install the
curl command and then cuba let's cube C
and then cube ADM how we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cube let's cubic c2 and
cube ADM and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt - get installed curl I'm
gonna get a prompt you can say yes for
that and then after this we'll go ahead
and install communities so the first
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's gonna be sudo curl - s and then
we have a long URL which is HTTP
packages cloud google.com apt dark apt -
key GPG sudo apt - key there we go my
type over there okay now we have to go
ahead and change permissions of like
folder so we do that with sudo CH mo d
777 slash etc slash apt sources.list dot
d alright we're good okay now you want
to go ahead and open up your text editor
and we're gonna make actual edits and
we're going to create a simple file and
so what we are typing is the find
command d b HT t bt apt - dot kubernetes
dot io / kubernetes - xenial main and
we're gonna save this file in the etc
folder and then look for and then apt
just gonna move down a little bit and
there we have it and we're gonna save it
in the apt - get updates and we're gonna
name this file as kubernetes dots list
and we'll save that and then we can
close out and no pattern go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
if there are any updates again so we're
gonna go ahead and run apt - get update
and it's going
run any updates from what we've created
and we want to check what's in the
folder and so we do cat slash accept et
et Cie such a PT such sources dot this
dot d such kubernetes dot list and there
we are it shows what we have in that
text file and so we're gonna go ahead
and we're going to install cubelet cubic
cubic to and cube ATM but first we're
gonna have to initialize the master I'm
going to show you it what you an error
you would get if you were to install
cubelet and the other files too quickly
you get a fine error
so we have installed cubelet QB a DM
cube actor Thank You Bonetti CNI and so
we'll go ahead and use sudo swap - - - a
and now we're going to initialize the
Massa note how we're going to do that
with sudo q ADM in it and this will take
a few minutes for it to initialize
so that's all done all right so we're
going to play the pod to a network and
we have to come on so we're going to use
we use sudo cube root cube CTL apply and
then we were a long path work to type
out which is Dasha HTTP raw github
content calm
coreos final master documentation cube -
file dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're gonna do that by creating
mmk TR Dash P and then we have dollar
sign home - cube I'll create that new
directory and sudo CP - I and then the
path will be etc - kubernetes lad MnDOT
Co and net and then da sign home slash
cubed slash config and then final one
will be sudo CH o WN DOS I'm I've been
praying I D - you close paren : da sign
a brand ID / - G close paren door sign
home / q / config alright now we're
going to go ahead and deploy and let's
see oh yeah I think I have a typo my
command here yep oh yes I did have a
typo and so um I've got that incorrect
now so documentation is that you spoke
with the t-nut in this and then we're
gonna go ahead and we're going to put in
the next line just sudo cubic cube CTL
apply Dutch - f and then we're just
going to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be a see all of the pods
that we have in our network and so we're
going to do that by writing the command
sudo Kubik CEO TCL I get pods - all - -
namespaces and it should list all of our
puds we only have one there yeah there's
all of our content now we're going to so
there's only one notes let's see what we
have here so we're gonna use come on
sudo you know cubic TL get nerds no we
are just one node so our final step is
to actually go ahead and deploy a
service and so what we're gonna go ahead
is deploy the ng IMX and service and
we're gonna do that with the command
sudo cubic CTL
run - - image equals n GI and X and
we're going to put this into port 80 so
it's going to be
gix - AB - - port equals 80 - -
environment
EMV equals a wound cone open quotes a
domain equals cluster closed quotes
and we're gonna write one more come on
which is pseudo cube CTL exposed
deployments ngi next - app - - port
equals 80 - - name equals ng INX - HTTP
and once we've done this we will be able
to then run the command - ecchi see our
services and they'll be quite a few of
them and our final command is sudo
docker PS - eh anyway quite a lot of
lists quite a lot of services listed so
there you are that's the instructions on
how to get docker up and running and
with some basic commands and it is worth
going through a few times to again get
right but once you actually have to the
kubernetes where I'm up and running and
managing your document environment in
containers it's extremely powerful thank
you for taking the time to better
understand kubernetes we hope that you
are getting value out of this
information if you liked this video
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
and the notification bell if you have
any questions about the kubernetes
infrastructure you're implementing and
you don't know where to get the answer
from post the question below or we'll
have one of our technicians look at it
and reply to you good luck with your
infrastructure on kubernetes hi there if
you liked this video subscribe to the
simply learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here